APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEETING TO ORDER -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
FLORENTINO HERE FORTINO HERE
BATES BATES HERE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE HELL.
HELL HERE JONES JONES HERE WE
CASKEY HERE WE CASKEY HERE.
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE FORTY
EIGHT BILLS HERE TODAY. TWO OF
WHICH ARE TO PASS.
THE REIGNING PARADING BILLS ARE
SUSPENSE ITEMS SEVERAL BILLS ON
FILE WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY.
SP THREE SIXTY SEVEN WAY SO.
HAS BEEN APPROVED AS A TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT AM REPORT DIRECTLY
TO FOUR SP ONE EIGHTY NINE
MINING.
WILL BE CONSIDERED NEXT WEEK.
AS A REMINDER I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE OUR MESSAGE THE
AUDIENCE AND MEMBERS THAT
TESTIMONY SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM.
RE LITIGATING THE POLICY -- AND
WILL -- JUST GET GOING SOUTH HI
SEEMED WAS MISTER BELL HERE
MISTER BELL IS HERE.
MISTER BELL PLEASE COME UP TO
YOU ARE.
I HAVE YOU WAITING PRESENTATION
ON SIX NINE ONE FIFTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE EIGHTY TWO IN PRESENTING ON
FIVE IS THAT.
YOUR PREFERENCES -- THANK YOU
MISTER BELL AND POLICE OBVIOUSLY
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
PHYSICAL OR YOUR WITNESSES TO
THE FISCAL.
AND WITH THAT WILL OPEN UP ON SP.
FIVE GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SP FIVE IS PART OF A PACKAGE OF
BILLS SO.
THE THE CENTER REQUIRE AN I. R.
HAVE INTRODUCES SURE HE'S THE
JOINT OFFER WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
THE PACKAGE IS BASED ON INPUT
GATHERED THROUGH A SERIES OF
PUBLIC HEARINGS WE COULD WE
CONVENED ACROSS THE STATE THIS
FALL.
THE DEALS WITH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INVESTMENT.
AND FOR ABOUT HOUSING INVESTMENT
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA -- THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT HAS HAD A OVERALL
NEGATIVE FISCAL EFFECT ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BY -- FEELING TO PRODUCE THE
NECESSARY. HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND NEW HOUSING UNITS PER
YEAR.
COMPANIES DON'T WANT TO LOCATE
CALIFORNIA IF THEY CAN'T.
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS RESULTS -- ALSO.
ANOTHER CAUSES INCURRED BY
GOVERNMENT THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ON THE STREETS LAST
YEAR.
AND OUT OF TWO POINT TWO MILLION
PEOPLE THAT ARE LOW INCOME OR
VERY LOW INCOME RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS.
THEY'RE COMPETING FOR SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOMES SO.
THIS IS.
A TREMENDOUS IMPACT [inaudible]
ON THE LOWER INCOME.
RESIDENTS THE CALIFORNIA.
AND IT LEAVES A HUNDRED ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
LOIS INCOME.
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
HOUSING.
AND RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS
REQUIRING MORE GOVERNMENT
SUBSIDY.
TO ON THE OTHER SIDE -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN ONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO
BUILD SHELTERS.
AND SHORT TERM HOUSING IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION.
INEFFICIENT WITHOUT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PERMANENT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO THIS BILL
MAKES THE STATE A LONG TERM.
FINANCIAL PARTNER. TO MERELY
CONSTRUCTS THE NEEDED HOUSING
FOR HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
BUILDS UP -- TO EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW AND REHABILITATED
HOUSING UNITS -- AND IS
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO COLLABORATE.
ON STATE APPROVED COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WOULD CREEP
WHICH SHOULD BE FUNDED BY
REDUCING.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS MADE TO THE
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE AUGMENTATION
FUN.
ZERO INFERENCES WILL BE PAID.
TO THE HOUSING OF THE NEEDY LOW
VERY LOW.
AND MODERATE INCOME AS WELL AS
TRANSIT OUR PRIORITY PROJECTS.
SP FIVE CREATES A CAP ON FUNDS --
VILLE IT NOW VIA ITS --
PROPOSING A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN.
202-200-2200 FIFTY MILLION.
AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND AFTER THE
PROGRAM HAS RAMPED UP THE TOTAL
GENERAL FUND SPENDING.
CANNOT EXCEED TWO MILLION
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY THE
STATE GENERAL FUND WOULD BE TO
BACK FILL THE SCHOOL LAW SCHOOL
REVENUE.
THE LEGISLATURE UNDER THE BILL
CAN SUSPEND -- PLANS DURING
FISCAL DOWNTURNS.
THAT SOUND LIKE REDEVELOPMENT
LOG THE FISCAL.
REVENUE FOR REDEVELOPMENT WOULD
JUST CONTINUE ON WITHOUT ANY
CONTROL BY THE STATE THIS ALLOWS.
A SUSPENSION.
THE BILL ALIGNS.
WITH OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS WE NOW HAVE. TO INSURE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL NON STATE GENERAL
FUNDS.
THESE INVESTMENTS GENERATE.
IN TEN OF FEDERAL FUNDS ABOUT
THREE TIMES THE INVESTMENT.
OF OF THE STATE SO FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM SO IF YOU INVEST ONE
DOLLAR YOU'RE GETTING THREE
DOLLARS ADDITIONAL.
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TAX
CREDITS.
THE LEGISLATION ALSO ROSE WITH
SCHOOL COUNT ABILITY PROVISIONS
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND TO ENSURE
FUNDS AND ALWAYS SPENT ON DISNEY
PROJECTS.
AND OR NOT OR OR IT'S A STATE
COMMITTEE. TO REVIEW AND MONITOR
THE FISCAL -- OVER START ON PART
OF THE STATE -- THE COMMITTEE IS
EMPOWERED TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION WITH LOCALS DO NOT MEET
YOUR PLANET CHAPTERS.
AND THOSE THOSE ISSUES ARE NOT
ADDRESSED IN ANY REDEVELOPMENT.
LAW WAS NOT ADDRESSED -- READ%
THE FORMER REDEVELOPMENT LOST SO
THIS PUTS THE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES.
AND THE STRONG CONTROL BY THE
STATE.
AS OPPOSED TO JUST HAVING
[inaudible]
OF REDEVELOPMENT RESTORED.
IN CALIFORNIA SO I HAVE A TURTLE
MY WITNESSES MISTER CHAIRMAN --
WE HAVE DOWNTOWN MUSHI FROM THE
CARPENTERS AND LEAGUE OF CITIES
ALSO.
HIS REPRESENTATIVES OF DOWNTURN
OVER YOUR BRAIN PLEASE OBVIOUSLY
FISCAL ISSUES.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS -- DAN
KELLUM GM A RESEARCHER WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
REGIONAL COUNCIL -- WE'RE
PLEASED TO OFFER OUR SUPPORT FOR
SP.
FIVE AND ALSO TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE RESULTS OF A STUDY THAT WE
DID IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
WERE USED IN IN PLAN INPUT
OUTPUT MODEL TO EXAMINE THE
POTENTIAL ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
THE DIRECT INVESTMENTS.
AS WELL AS THE ADDITIONAL
LEVERAGE FUNDS FROM SENATE BILL
FIVE AS IT WAS INTRODUCED.
OUR MODEL IS BASED ON ANALYSIS
OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
AND LIKE THE PROGRAM WE EXPECT
THE STATE'S DIRECTEMENT DIRECT
INVESTMENT FROM SP FIVE TO BE
LEVERAGED OVER THREE TIMES FROM
LOW INCOME TAX CREDITS.
FROM OTHER FEDERAL FUNDS FROM
OTHER LOCAL SOURCES AND FROM
PRIVATE FUNDS.
THESE INVESTMENTS COULD
TRANSLATE INTO OVER SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
INCLUDING OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT PER
YEAR BY.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OUR ANALYSIS
ALSO SHOWS THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY
NINE THESE INVESTMENTS CAN
PRODUCE OVER EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
NEW AND REHABILITATED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAX REVENUE. TWENTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LABOR INCOME
AND SUPPORT APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
JOBS.
INCLUDING A HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FAMILY SUPPORTING
PREVAILING WAGE CONSTRUCTION
JOBS WITH HEALTH AND RETIREMENT
BENEFITS WHILE OPENING UP
APPRENTICESHIP OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VETERANS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND
OTHER FOLKS JUST BEGINNING THEIR
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS.
SP FIVE WILL NOT ONLY HELP US
MEET THE STATE'S URGENT NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ITS
EFFECTS WILL RIPPLE THROUGHOUT
OUR ECONOMY.
WILL RESULT IN MORE JOBS
INCREASED CONSUMER SPENDING AND
MORE TAX REVENUE IT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN STATES CURRENT AND
FUTURE WORK FORCE OUR HOUSING
MARKET AND OUR ECONOMY.
AND THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS ARE PLEASE TO OFFER
OUR SUPPORT THANKS THANKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
DAVID SANDER I'M VICE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF RANCHO CORDOVA
ALTHOUGH COME YOU'RE WEARING
SEVERAL HATS.
I HAVE SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT HERE
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION I AM
ALSO THE CURRENT CHAIR OF SAY
COG WHICH IS THE COG FOR THE
SACRAMENTO REGION.
I'VE SERVED ON THE LC BOARD AND
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
BOARD.
AND I HAVE SERVED AS A POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THEM IN TERMS OF
OLD SUBURBAN ISSUES AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
AND SO I'M COMING TO YOU TODAY
AS A PERSON IS WEARING MANY HATS
BECAUSE OF ICE WHERE VENTURA.
WHERE WE HAVE FULL SYMBOL OF ART
IN THE HEART OF OUR OLD SUBURB
OLD COMMERCIAL CORRIDOR?
IN DESPERATE NEED OF REINVENTION --
WE HAVE SOUGHT ABOUT TO DO THAT
SINCE OUR CORPORATION TWO
THOUSAND TWO AND FOUND A GREAT
NUMBER OF BARRIERS NOW THIS IS A
BOWL OF OUR YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH BECAUSE IT'S JUST A FEW
MILES FROM HERE.
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR MILES OF
TRANSIT STRETCHING ALONG THAT
OLD COMMERCIAL QUARTER THAT USED
TO BE HIGHWAY FIFTY BUT NO
LONGER AS OTHER SIX LIGHT RAIL
STATIONS ALONG THE CORRIDOR AND
WE ARE UNABLE DUE TO ECONOMICS.
TO STIMULATE ANY SORT OF
TRANSITORY DEVELOPMENT AT THOSE
STATIONS AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
MOTIVATES ME TO COME BEFORE YOU
HEARD TODAY.
AS CHAIR OF SAY COG -- WE ARE
AWARE THAT WE NEED TO DECREASE
OUR GREEK GREENHOUSE GAS IMPACT --
AND INCREASE THE REDUCTION 219%
SOURCES SAY CUT REGION WHERE
DESPERATELY STUDYING HOW DO WE
ACHIEVE THAT.
IN OUR REGION AND THE ANSWER IS
ABOUT 75% OF OUR EFFORT OUGHT TO
BE DIRECTED TOWARDS INFILL. FOR
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING AGENCY
BUT IN PHIL IS THE SOLUTION
ALLOWING PEOPLE LIVE CLOSER TO
JOBS HIS RANCH ROVERS JOB RICH --
AND NOT HAVE THOSE LONG COMMUTE --
DISTANCES IN THEIR COMMUTES.
SO HOW DO WE ACHIEVE THIS.
I'M WELL AWARE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES OF INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND I CAN TELL YOUR
BRIEF STORY ABOUT WHAT LOOKS
LIKE IN MY COMMUNITY WHERE JOBS
RICH WE HAVE A GROWING GREEN
EDGE IN RANCHO CORDOVA WE HAVE A
LARGE OLD URBAN SUBURBAN.
CORRIDOR AND NEED TO RE
INVENTION A RESTAURANT WANTED TO
COME ON ONE PARTICULAR SIDE OF
TOWN THEY WERE ALSO INTEREST IN
BEING AND IN FULL SIGHT.
IT TURNS OUT THEIR COSTS FOR
THAT IN FULL SIGHT ROUGHLY
DOUBLE OF WHAT THE GREENFIELD
COST ONCE.
AND IT WAS DOUBLE BECAUSE THEY
FOUND SITUATIONS LIKE -- YES THE
REPLACING OLD RESTAURANT THAT
WAS THERE AND THERE WAS A GREASE
TRAP ALREADY IN PLACE BUT THE
SEWER DISTRICT AND STATE
REGULATIONS.
AND STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT YOU
REPLACE THAT OLD NINETEEN
SIXTIES GREEK GREASE TRAP SO
THAT IT MEETS THE REGULATIONS
WERE PASSED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND THE
COST OF DOING SO TURNING IT FROM
A SIX FOOT TRAPPED UNDER SIX AND
A HALF FOOT TRAP WOULD COST THAT
RESTAURANT ABOUT A QUARTER OF A
MILLION TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS REPEATED ON THROUGH EIGHTY
A THROUGH -- POWER NEEDS THROUGH
WATER NEEDS THROUGH DRAINAGE
MEANS VARIOUS DIFFERENT
GOVERNMENTS NOT UNDER CONTROL OF
THE CITY UNTIL THE COST OF THAT
INFO RESTAURANT WAS LITERALLY
DOUBLE.
WHAT YOU WOULD SEE IN GREENFIELD
SORTED IT END UP OBVIOUSLY IN
GREENFIELD THAT WAS THE ONLY
THING?
THAT IS ECONOMICALLY POSSIBLE.
SO MY CITY IS HERE ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WERE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO SEE THAT IN
FILL DEVELOPMENT WE NEED TO SEE
THAT HOUSING ON OUR OLD
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS AND ASSURE
SAY COG.
AND IN MY NATIONAL POST I CAN
TELL YOU EVERY JURISDICTION IN
OUR STATE EVERY JURISDICTION IN
THE COUNTRY IS FACING THE SAME
CHALLENGE HOW DO YOU REINVEST
ALONG THESE OLD SUBURBAN
CORRIDORS.
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION SP
FIVE IS CERTAINLY A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IT WILL HELP US
KNOCKED DOWN SOME OF THOSE
BARRIERS IT'LL DO THINGS AS AS
BORING AS FINANCE THE
REPLACEMENT OF AGREE STRAP --
WITHOUT ARGUING THE SPECIFICS OF
IT BUT THOSE SORTS OF BARRIERS
ARE WHAT STOP US FROM STARTING.
TRANSFERRING TO THE HOME IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE THINK THIS BILL
WILL HELP NOT ONLY US BUT A LOT
OF CITIES IN THE STATE ISSUE
THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE DO YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION.
BUCKLEY ON WE HAVE A THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
NICCOLO DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
MR REMEMBERS DAVID JONES ABOUT
THE CITIES OF BURBANK GLENDALE
PASADENA SOUTH PASADENA THE
CITIES OF MARIN AND SUPPORT.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN TIM CRAM INTO
BEHALF THE INTERNATIONAL BOPPARD
ENGINEERS IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS GENESIS
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATE ON WHO
DROWNED THE STATE COUNCIL LABORS
AND SUPPORT.
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MEREDITH'S AMBER CAN
SUPPORT.
HE'S DONE HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PARMER CESSATION THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS
CALIFORNIA.
MR MEMBERS CHASE RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE THE MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS STILL
UNITARY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE DON'T HAVE A FILE
ON THIS MEASURE.
ANY QUESTIONS.
GO AHEAD MR CASH CAN BE.
CENTRE BELL YOUR PROPONENTS ARE
TALKING ABOUT -- THE OPPORTUNITY
OF HAVING OTHER -- FEDERAL FUNDS
PRIVATE FUNDS OTHER FUNDS BEING
LEVERAGE LEVERAGE -- TO INCREASE
THE POOL OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT IF.
THESE FUNDS WERE NOT WE WERE NOT
INVADING THE E. WRAPPED AND WE
SIMPLY LET'S SAY -- MODIFIED SP
TWO FROM LAST YEAR SO WE
ACTUALLY DO CATCH EVERY
TRANSACTION THE SALE NEW SALES
THAT WOULD CREATE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WOULDN'T THOSE
FUNDS THAT.
YOU'RE PROPONENTS ARE TALKING
ABOUT LEVERAGE WOULD THAT ALSO
BE LEVERAGE AVAILABLE -- FOR THE
DEVELOPERS -- I CAN PROPOSE A
BOWL OF BILL THAT HAS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE OR A COUPLE OF A
BILL THAT -- HAS A MAJORITY VOTE.
CERTAINLY WE HAD.
NEW TAX REVENUE FROM SOMEWHERE --
THAT REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE --
WHICH IS.
CONCEIVABLE NOBODY'S PROPOSE
THAT HOWEVER -- I THINK IT COULD
BE DONE SURE RIGHT ANY KIND OF
NEW REVENUE WOULD [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY -- THE MATCH IT HAS
TO BE MATCHED.
TO ROGER X. THAT QUALIFY UNDER
THE FEDERAL.
TAX CREDIT -- PROGRAM.
IF THEIR MATCH TO THOSE FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT YOU CAN GET THE THE
THE HE REVENUE FROM THE FEDERAL
TAX CREDIT.
IT'S ABOUT THREE TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT YOU INVEST
IN THIS BOOK PERHAPS IF WE
LOOKED AT THE CAPTAIN TREAT HIS
ONE YEAR PROPONENTS IS TALKING
ABOUT -- TRANSITORY AT
DEVELOPMENT FOR MAYBE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION IF THE FLOOR OF A
CAP AND TRADE WOULD GO FROM
FIFTEEN DOLLARS TO THIRTY
DOLLARS THAT WOULD DOUBLE THE
REVENUE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE SO
WOULD.
THE CURRENTLY SIX HUNDRED
MILLION IT GOES TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH WOULD DOUBLE TO
ONE POINT TWO MILLION WOULDN'T
THOSE FUNDS BE AVAILABLE TO LOW
INCOME TAX CREDITS.
PRIVATE FUNDS IN OTHER FEDERAL
FUNDS AS WELL AS DOUBLING THE
AMOUNT A TRANSITORY IN
DEVELOPMENT IS AT THE TIME I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE MECHANISM OF
ALL THE REVENUE INCREASE TAX --
ANY KIND OF REVENUE INCREASE
EXPANDING THE TOP MAKING THE TAX
CREDIT.
WHICH REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE
AGAIN.
THAT CAN BE DONE IT COULD BE ANY
KIND OF REVENUE LIKE THAT.
IS A COULD BE MATCHED WITH
FEDERAL -- FEDERAL FUNDS LIKE I
LIKE TO POINT OUT THE I HAVE NOT
SEEN A PROPOSAL DOING THAT IT
CAN BE DONE [inaudible]
HOWEVER -- WELL WE DO NEED WHAT
WE DO KNOW WE NEED IS AN ONGOING
SOURCE OF REVENUE THAT STUDY ON
GOING.
AND SET UP IN A WAY WHERE CAN
EASILY USE BY CITIES WHICH TH
STARS.
SO THE THIS.
PROPOSAL DOES NOT REQUIRE -- THE
TWO THIRDS VOTE THAT DO YOU.
WOULD REQUIRE FOR THOSE OTHER
ITEMS WELL I MISSED THREE CHURCH
I DON'T BELIEVE CAP AND TRADE
AUCTION WHICH HAS BEEN
DETERMINED BY THE COURTS TO NOT
BE IFFY AND NOT BE ATTACKS WOULD
REQUIRE TWO THIRDS BUT I JUST
WANTTO KNOW.
THE MECHANISMS THAT TREE THAT
YOU -- PEOPLE YES AGREE WITH
THAT BUT OKAY -- FIGHTING.
DID YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH I
THINK -- I THINK GO WITH
UNLIMITED REDEVELOPMENT IN THE
CRISIS THAT WE HAD IN THE BUDGET
I MEAN WE HAD.
WE HAD A GROUP OF PROGRAMS THAT
ENCOURAGE -- COMMUNITY
INVESTMENTS -- IT RICK IT DID
NOT.
IT HAS SOME FAILINGS.
AND THIS BILL -- WINDSOR REQUIRE
AND I WENT OUT AND LOOKED AT
VARIOUS WAYS WE TRIED.
TO DEVISE A WAY WHERE WE CAN
CORRECT THOSE PROBLEMS.
MAKE CORRECTIONS AND MAKE IT
PHYSICALLY MORE RESPONSIBLE.
AND WE CAME UP WITH THIS BILL.
AND IN MY AREA -- THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE PASSED HOUSING
MEASURES.
HOWEVER THE STATE NEEDS TO COME
UP WITH WITH THEIR FAIR SHARE.
OF REVENUE SO WE NEED TO BE A
PARTNER ON ON GOING BASIS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL THIS IS
THE ONLY BILL THAT ACTUALLY DOES
THAT.
THAT'S OUT NOW PENDING IN THE
LEGISLATORS GONE THROUGH THE
POLICY COMMITTEE SO.
THIS IS THIS IS PRETTY MUCH A IN
MY AREA -- THE DISINVESTMENT IN
MY AREA IS NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN
MEASURE FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT.
WHEN A COMPANY RELOCATES TO
ANOTHER AREA?
AND A HIGH TECH AREA BECAUSE OF
THEY DON'T HAVE HOUSING.
BUT IT IS.
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
[inaudible]
FOR RELOCATION.
OUT OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BY [inaudible]
THE HI TECH COMPANIES THAT I
REPRESENT IN MY AREA IT'S THE
NUMBER ONE REASON.
SO I REGION I VOTE ON THIS THIS
WOULD HELP THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND IT WOULD BE A
BENEFIT TO THE STATE ON A
PHYSICAL BASIS.
THANK YOU MISTER BELL I WOULD
NOTE THAT -- I WAS ONE OF THE
HANDFUL OF PEOPLE WHO DID NOT
VOTE TO DISSOLVE REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES BACK WHEN I WAS ON THE
TABLE SO I'M.
PROUD OF MY POSITION THEN IN
FACT THEN I SAID HOW CAN YOU DO
AWAY WITH THE STATE'S ONLY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PLAN WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE A REPLACEMENT.
AND HERE WE ARE A DECADE LATER
STILL TRYING TO HAVE A
REPLACEMENT SO -- CERTAINLY IN
CONCEPT -- YOU HAVE A YOU HAVE A
FRIENDLY FRIENDLY CHAIR THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE TEN THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD WITH
MISTER MCGUIRE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COALITION
YOU PUT TOGETHER IT'S IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION IT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I SAW MR ARCHER LET IN
THE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE -- SP FIVE FIVE TWO
WHICH IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT.
SP FIVE FIVE TWO A GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- I'M BEFORE YOU TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
TWO IT'S VERY SIMPLE SENATE -- A
SIMPLE SUNSET BILL. TO THE
SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE TWO WILL
DELETE -- THE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SUNSET.
AND MAKE PERMANENT THE DOOR TO
DOOR HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
COLLECTION PROGRAM -- THIS
PROGRAM IS PROVEN TO WORK FOR
MANY CITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND AS NOTED THE COMMITTEE HAS
ANALYZED.
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT CUT
CODIFIES EXISTING PRACTICE.
AND THERE IS NO PHYSICAL IMPACT
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL AND
FOR THIS REASON I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE [inaudible]
YEAH WITNESSES.
SHANE NONE NO OPPOSITION WE LIKE
THOSE OFF THIS FINE WE HAVE A
MOTION THIS FINANCE HAVE A FILE
NO FILE NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE -- I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU ALL NIGHT -- THIRD YEAR I
BOTH THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BRADFORD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTENT TINO.
TINO I'D BATES BATES BY BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I HILL HILL I JONES
JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY I SIX ZERO WE'RE ALL
HERE RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR THANK YOU.
I SEE NO OTHER AUTHORS HERE SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE DONE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU THIS OUT THANK YOU MR
PELL'S SP FIVE IS OUT SO WE WILL
GO TO THE TOP.
WITH SP TWO BY MR GLAZER.
I WAS THERE ANYBODY HERE TO
SPEAK ON THIS SPEAK TO WHICH IS
STATE LONGITUDINAL STUDENT
DATABASE ANYBODY HERE TO OPPOSE
IT FINANCE THE FILE.
NO FILE -- WITHOUT OBJECTION OR
QUESTION ESPY TWO WILL GO.
TO SERVICE SPENCE SP FOURTEEN BY
MR GLAZER HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE
FILE NO FILE I DON'T SEE ANY
HANDS GO UP.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FOURTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
SIX MISTER BELL ON RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT LAND -- ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE NO
FILE NO FILE SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP SP.
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE S. B.
NINE MISTER BELL LOW INCOME
HOUSING.
CREDITS ANY SUPPORT.
THE OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE.
NO QUESTIONS PRESS B. NINE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP ONE FIFTY MISTER
BELL FINANCIAL AID.
CHAFEE GRANT AWARDS SIR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE A FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP ONE FIFTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AS BEFORE.
SIXTY VEHICLES BY ANY ALL
REGISTRATION MR SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION.
THEIR FILE IF I KNOW FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FOUR SIXTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SP FIVE EIGHTY TWO BY MISTER
BELL JOOP MOVE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IS THERE SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION SERRA FILE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WOULD
KNOW THAT IT WILL RESULT IN
INCREASED COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH WOULD
BE APPROPRIATED FROM THE GENERAL
FUND.
OF THE COMMISSION ESTIMATES
STATE OPERATION COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND ANNUALLY TO
ADMINISTER THE ADDITIONAL GRANT
FUNDS.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIVE EIGHTY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP SEVEN
BY.
POURTANT TINO STATE HIGHWAY
ROUTE -- SEVEN TEN THERE'S NO
SUPPORT AND OPOSITION SIR FILE
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP.
SEVEN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP.
TWO SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
I DON'T SEE ANY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION.
IS NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION TO
SEVENTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
HAS BEFORE FOUR FIVE BY PORTENT
TINO ALCOHOL AND DRUG TREATMENT
YOUTH.
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE
YOU KNOW FILE.
THAT OBJECTION FOUR FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AND THEN MY LAST ONE
ON THE DOCKET LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
INCREASE -- CRISPY SEVEN TWENTY
NINE IS YOUR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP SEVEN
TWENTY NINE WE'LL GO TO SUSPEND
SMITH SKINNER SP.
FORTY TWO THE GETTING HOME SAY
FACT THEIR SUPPORT WE HAVE
SUPPORT.
JI LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE NO FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION IT'S
B. FORTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE --
SP SIXTY FIVE BY DOCTOR PAN
HEALTH COVERAGE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE.
THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE YOU KNOW FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION -- SEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM ANYBODY.
THAT OBJECTION SP SIXTY FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SP FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT A SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
TRAINING MENTAL HEALTH BY DOCTOR
PAN I THINK I'M A CO AUTHOR OF
THAT -- ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE FILE NO FILE ANY
MY COLLEAGUES NO QUESTIONS THAT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE.
TWENTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP SIX TWELVE DR PAN
HEALTHCARE DATA REPORTING IS
THERE ANY SUPPORT.
AND OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE A FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS S. B. SIX
TWELVE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB SIX SIXTY PAN EDUCATION
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS.
THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE FILE NO FILE OTHER
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS ARE WITHOUT%
OBJECTION SP.
SIX SIX ZERO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP ONE SIXTY TWO BY MS
GALA JOHNNY ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING. TWENTY
SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION -- FILE NO FILE
NO FILE [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS ESPYS ONE
SIXTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SP ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY MR REQUIRE
ON CAMPUS MARKETING.
IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
NOT BE GONE IN THE OTHER WAY IS
HER FILE A FILE NO FILE I SEE NO
HANDS GO UP SO WITHOUT QUESTIONS.
SP ONE EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
BEFORE NINE NINE MCGUIRE SCHOOL
MEALS CALIFORNIA GROWN PROGRAM.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
HIS THEIR OPPOSITION TO WE HAVE
A FILE NO FILE.
NO FILE HOPE IS USING THE SKINNY
LANDS.
YEAH THAT WOULD HELP -- ANY
QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP FOUR NINE NINE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ESPY TWO OH SEVEN BY MISTER TADO
MEDIC COW ASTHMA PREVENTION
SERVICES.
SIR ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION SERRA FILE FILE
NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP TWO OH SEVEN CO TWO SUSPENSE.
MR HERTZBERG HAS TWO BILLS SP
TWO SIXTY FIVE ON CHILD HUNGER
PREVENTION -- IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE -- NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP TWO SIX
FIVE ALTHOUGH THE SUSPENSE.
SP THREE EIGHTY NINE MY MISTER
HERZBERG ON MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS THERE SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS THEIR FILE FILE
NO FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS NONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP THREE EIGHTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
WILL MOVE ON TO MISTER ALLEN'S
BILLS -- SP TWO NINETY SIX CAL
GRANT IMMIGRANTS SEEKING ASYLUM.
ARE THERE ANY SUPPORTERS.
ANY OPPOSERS AS THEIR FILE FILE.
NO FAULT WE DO.
SEE THAT WE'RE GETTING YOUR
STEPS IN TODAY BRENDAN BIGGER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION WE DO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ALL RIGHT IS ANOTHER PERSON
COMING UP NOPE JUST SHIFTING
CHAIRS.
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE IS THERE
A FILE THE FILE NO FILE.
A SEEING NO QUESTIONS SP TWO
NINE SIX WILL GO -- TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP THREE
NINETY TWO ALAN GREEN CHEMISTRY
CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
AND WE DO HAVE [inaudible]
A SUPPORTER.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE FEAR
AND SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE OFFICE OF
MARYLAND BREED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS TIM CHESTED
WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
WERE CURRENTLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WORKING WITH THE
PROPONENTS AND CENTER ALLEN'S
OFFICE ON SOME LANGUAGE THAT WE
THINK.
NOT ONLY COULD ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY
REDUCE COSTS TO THE TSC THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
OUR SHARE FILE THE FILE NO
FINALLY QUESTION SING NONE.
THAT OBJECTIONS SP THREE NINETY
TWO BY MISTER ALLEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SP SIX EIGHTY SIX CALIFORNIA
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD ACT --
THEIR SUPPORT I KNOW THEIR
SUPPORT ON THIS.
ONE I GOT TEXT THIS MORNING.
YES THE MOST IMPORTANT INDICATOR
THESE DAYS I SUPPOSE I'M SUSAN
WALTERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY FUN HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX EIGHTY SIX AS A COST
EFFECTIVE MEASURE TO CHANGE
UNDERPERFORMINGSCHOOLS IN LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS FROM PRISON
PIPELINES TO CRADLE TO COLLEGE
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FOR ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A FILE NO
FILE -- FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS SP.
SIX EIGHTY SIX WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION --
I'VE YOU GUYS CALLED MS RUBIO
SERGEANTS.
HE REACHED OUT TO MS REBELS
OFFICE.
OKAY GREAT -- WE WILL GO TO HER
SP SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN WHICH IS
WAY PRESENTATION ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INSTRUCTION. FOR
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN ANY OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE FILE NO FILE WILL
SKIP OVER SHOW WITHOUT OBJECTION
SP SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN GOES THE
SUSPENSE.
WILL SKIP OVER THREE OH NINE FOR
THE MOMENT MOVE ON THE SP THREE
SEVENTEEN MY MISS KATHY YEAR A
WASTE PROHIBITED CHEMICALS.
THEIR SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION IS
HER FILE FILE NO FILE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
THREE SEVENTEEN CAVALIER WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE -- WILL MOVE ON TO
MR KILLS THREE BILLS THANK YOU
MISTER HILL FOR WAVING
PRESENTATION -- SP THREE TWENTY
FIVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AS TEIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE A FILE.
NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS --
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
THREE TWENTY FIVE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
MISTER HILL WORKERS COMPENSATION --
SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION IS HER
FILE THE FILE NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP FIVE FORTY FIVE
MISTER HILL THE WHY A MISSION
INTERLOCK DEVICES.
SIR SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
FIVE FOUR FIVE BY MISTER HILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO MS MITCHELL'S TWO
BILLS SP THREE SIXTY ONE MEDIC
COW HEALTH HOME PROGRAMS AS
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE
THE FILE YOU KNOW FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS.
SP THREE SIXTY ONE WILL GO TO A
A SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
BEFORE SIX FOUR BY MISS MITCHELL
DIGNITY IN PREGNANCY CHILDBIRTH
ACT.
YOUR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
SHARE FILE NEW FILE.
NO FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS AT SP FOUR
SIX FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SP THREE SIXTY FIVE BY MISTER
ROGERS SO CAL WORKS IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE.
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE A FILE
THERE'S NO FILE AN SP.
THREE SIXTY FIVE OUT QUESTIONS
THAT WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MOVING ON TO
MISTER BRADFORD SPILLS AND AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER BRADFORD FOR
WAVING PRESENTATION -- WE HAVE
SP FOUR TO SIX MISTER BRADFORD
CSU THE DYE MILLIE FELLOWS
PROGRAM MY FORMER HOW CAN I NOT
A LOVE A DIME IN IT MY FORMER
SEAT MATE.
WHO USED TO CALL ME JUST FOREVER
HE'S COMING GODFATHER JUNIOR?
THIS IS A HE WAS THE REAL
GODFATHER AND I WAS JUST JUNIOR.
AND FOR SIX YEARS HE CALLED ME
JUNIOR.
AND THEN ONE DAY I READ MATT IS
WIFE AND SHE SAID SO YOUR JUNIOR.
SO BUT NO ONE ELSE OUT THERE CAN
CALL ME JUNIOR JUST THE LATE
MISTER DONNELLY.
AND MRS DONNELLY SO ANYWAY --
ANY SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE THE FILE NO FILE
SP FOUR TWENTY SIX BY MISTER
BRADFORD WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AS BEFORE FIVE FIVE MISTER
BRADFORD FINANCIAL AND
EMPOWERMENT FUND THEIR SET UP WE
DO HAVE SOMEBODY ARE YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION.
SUPPORT COME ON UP.
DANIEL CANDLE BECAUSE OUR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN OUR
THIRTEEN PARTNERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION SERRA FILE THE FILE
NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FOUR FIVE
FIVE BY MISTER BRADFORD WILL GO
THE SUSPENSE SP FIVE SEVEN FIVE
BY MISTER BRADFORD CAL GRANT
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY.
THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THEIR FILE THE
FILE YOU KNOW FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIVE SEVEN
FIVE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP
FIVE NINE FIVE BY MISTER
BRADFORD CANNABIS STATE FEE
WAIVERS.
THAT WE DO HAVE.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA'S ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS HER FILE THE FILE
NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIVE NINE
FIVE BY MISTER BRADFORD WILL GO
THE SUSPENSE.
AS BEFORE SEVEN ONE BY MR STERN
SUBPOENAS FORM AND SERVICES
THEIR SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION IS
THEIR FILE FILE NO FILE --
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION BEFORE SEVEN ONE BY MR
STERN WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP
FIVE HUNDRED MISTER MORALE.
VETERANS EDUCATION.
THEIR SUPPORT. TO OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE NO
FILE SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION MISTER MORALES.
SP FIVE HUNDRED WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MS BATES SP FIVE FOUR ONE ON
SCHOOL SAFETY LOCKDOWN DRILLS --
IS THERE SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION MISS BATES THANK YOU
FOR WAIVING PRESENTATIONS -- ANY
COMMENTS OTHER THAN THIS IS A
GOOD BILL -- WITH THEIR FILE IF
I KNOW FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
FIVE FOUR ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
WILL MOVE TO MISTER ROTH SINCE
WE DISPENSE WITH MR ARCHULETA.
SP FIVE FIVE FOUR ADULT SCHOOL
STUDENTS IS THEIR SUPPORT COME
ON UP.
GOOD MORNING BRIANNA BRANDS OF
THE CALIFORNIA AS COALITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE NEW FILE NO
FILES WITH THING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SP FIVE FIVE FOUR MISTER ROCK
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE HAS TO BE
FIVE SIX THREE MISTER ROTH
COLLEGE AND CAREER ACCESS
PATHWAY GRANT.
YOUR SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE
THE FILE NO FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
ASKED ME FIVE SIX THREE BY
MISTER ROTH WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MOVING ON TO MISS JACKSON.
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SP FIVE SIXTY
ONE IS THEIR SUPPORT
THEIR OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE THE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIVE SIXTY
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
I. S. B. FIVE NINETY TWO BY
MISTER WEINER BORDER BARBERING
IN COSMETOLOGY.
IS THERE SUPPORT THEIR
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A FILE THE
FILE.
THERE'S NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS ON FIVE NINETY TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP FIVE NINETY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AND THEN SP SIX FIVE SEVEN BY
MISTER MINING CANNABIS
CULTIVATION REPORTING.
IS THERE A SUPPORT AS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS AS
TO BE SIX FIVE SEVEN BY MISTER
MINING FOR GO TO SUSPENSE.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING EXCEPT MS RUBIO'S
THREE OH NINE CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE CALL MS RUBIO
[inaudible]
FOUR FIVE SO WE ARE
GOING TO HEAR SP THREE OH NINE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR CITIZENS TAX
CONTRIBUTION FUND AND THAT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY AND
PRESENTING A SPEED THRILL.
NINE WHICH WOULD REMOVE THE
MINIMUM DONATION REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
CITIZEN.
ADVOCACY VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
FUN MUST RACE IN ORDER TO REMAIN
LISTED ON THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHEN THE
PHONE WAS FIRST CREATED IT WAS
NOT DIRECTLY SUBJECT TO MINIMUM
CONTRIBUTIONS -- REQUIREMENT
UNTIL NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH
HAS BEEN BURDENSOME THESE PAST
FEW YEARS ACCORDING TO THE UC
BERKELEY LABOR CENTER THAT
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS. SIXTY
AND OLDER WILL GROW FROM SEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO TWELVE MILLION AND
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THIS AGENCY WE'VE
SEEN OVER TWO HUNDRED CSL BILLS.
SIGNED INTO LAW DIRECTING HANDS
IN THE LIFE OF OUR ELDERLY
COMMUNITY.
WHICH BENEFITS THE STATE IN THE
LONG RUN.
THE LOSS OF REVENUE IS A MINIMUM.
AT AN ESTIMATED EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONLY ACCORDING TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HOWEVER IT
DOES NOT AFFECT THE ABILITY OF
THE CSL TO CONTINUE. TO OBTAIN
DONATIONS.
HERE WITH ME I HAVE SOMEONE TO
TESTIFY IF HE ME JOHN POINTER
SISTERS HE SERVED ON THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEAD TO SAY
TURN WITHOUT A LIKE TO MEET HIM
TO TESTIFY ON MY BEHALF.
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC THIS UP.
AS BRIEF AS I POSSIBLY CAN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF TIME -- THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION OF SP.
THREE OH NINE CSL WAS ONE OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE TAX CHECK
OFF AT THIS TIME THERE WERE ONLY
FOUR FUNDS.
AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE NOW THIRTY
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
ABC. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
ORIGINALLY CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA PHONE FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS THE FUN WAS DESIGNED TO
CONDUCT.
ANNUAL SESSION IN SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES CONTINUOUSLY WITHOUT
REGARD TO FISCAL YEAR AND
THERE'S NO MINIMUM CONTRIBUTION
AMOUNT.
SP THREE OH NINE INSURERS CSL
REMAINS ON THE TAX CHECKOFF I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT INSURES
THAT THE REMAIN ESPECIALLY IN
THE CLIMATE RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT SP TWO
FORTY ONE AS A POSSIBLE -- BILL
AS WELL.
FINALLY SP THREE OH NINE IS A
KEY COMPONENT OF THIS IS SELF
FUNDING SOLUTIONS OUTLINED IN
THE THREE YEAR FUNDING.
PLAN INTRODUCED LAST YEAR TO THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER.
ONE A FINANCIAL PLANNER DID A
FINE TO REVISE FUNDING MODEL
THAT RECOGNIZED OUR STATE AGENCY
STATUS.
AND UTILIZE BOTH THE GENERAL
PHONE AS WELL AS THE STATE.
AS THE TAX CHECK OFF.
THE FUEL CELL IS THE LEGISLATIVE
CHAMPION [inaudible]
OF SENIORS.
THE LEGISLATION DEVELOPER CSO
MEMBERS IMPACTS THE LARGEST
SENIORS ACROSS THE STATE YOU
KNOW THE DEMOGRAPHICS.
SENIORS ARE DESTINED TO BECOME
THE LARGEST POPULATION SEGMENT
IN THE STATE.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT WE NEED AN
ORGANIZATION WITH THIRTY EIGHT
YEAR HISTORY OF ADVOCATING. FOR
SENIORS SP THREE OH NINE
PROVIDES CSL THE ABILITY. TO
CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
TAX CHECK OFF IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE I ASKED FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
THEIR FILE FIND A FILE NO FILE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM HIS REVIEW.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IT IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION YES THANK
YOU AS WE HEARD OR SEEN A
COMMUNITY IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
OF COURSE.
THERE AND PUT VERY VALUABLE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER HELP YOU
BUY A NANOSECOND -- WITHOUT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
POURTANT DINO I WANT TO KNOW I'D
BATES BATES I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I HILL -- HILL I JONES.
JONES I WE KOWSKI.
WE CASKEY I I'M PHYLLIS OUT
UNANIMOUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU -- COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
WE FINISHED.
QUICKLY TODAY DON'T GET SPOILED --
I IMAGINE IT'S GOING TO GET IT'S
GONNA GET LONGER.
AS THE WEEKS GO ON AND THANKS
ALL FOR BEING HERE WE'LL SEE YOU
NEXT WEEK